new titles are entering the Playstation
Plus game catalog on March 21st and if
you're looking to expand your collection
with post-apocalyptic action Tokyo
exorcisms and an unhinged goose and
you're in luck we got a little preview
of the lineup last month during the
state of play but now we know that 14
new games are being added to the
PlayStation Plus extra and premium tiers
as well as three more retro titles for
premium members only this month is
headlined by Uncharted Legacy of Thieves
collection naughty dog's remastered
versions of Uncharted 4 thief's end and
Uncharted the Lost Legacy fans of
explorative games can also look forward
to Chia and for anyone looking to do
some social alien extermination Rainbow
Six extraction will also be available
ghostwire Tokyo will transport you to an
iconic section of the city that has been
overrun with Phantoms and Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot is a fun action RPG that retells
the life story of Goku across his many
battles other games arriving include
Untitled Goose game Street Fighter 5
Champion Edition and life is strange
true colors for the PlayStation Classics
Library you can look forward to Slick
racing action with Ridge Racer Type 4
naughty simeons and ape Escape 2 and a
port of the PSP game siphon filter dark
mirror but ghostwire isn't just coming
to the Playstation Plus game catalog
it's also making its Xbox debut on Game
Pass on April 12th following a year of
PlayStation and PC exclusivity in
addition to coming to Xbox ghostwire
Tokyo we'll get an update on April 12th
the spider's threat update that adds a
new mode new locations to explore
additional cutscenes and quality of life
improvements the spider's thread mode
takes players into a 30 stage Gauntlet
with the aim of the player trying to
survive to the end the new enemies
include the Silent Gaze who is invisible
and the retribution which is described
as being elusive all these new updates
and more are coming to the PlayStation 5
and PC versions of ghostwire Tokyo as
well in other update news the patch
notes are now available for MW2 and
Warzone 2 season 2 reloaded which is
live right now the mid-season update
adds a new standard 6v6 map three new
game modes and a new raid episode to
multiplayer in addition to new
mid-season content the patch notes for
the big update reveal plenty of weapons
tuning and quality of life updates for
weapons balancing three popular like
machine guns were nerfed the seiken mg38
now has reduced damage range the rpk has
reduced walking speed and muzzle
velocity rail mg was hit with Nerfs to
damage range headshot damage and upper
torso damage on the competitive side the
patch notes also address a few new
restrictions to ranked play as the cast
off 762 assault rifle and all weapons
tuning are now restricted for the mode
while lacking on new content for Battle
Royale the season 2 reloaded update does
include several quality of life updates
for Warzone 2. for more of these patch
notes head on over to gamespot.com and
we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]